[Music]  we don't do who he'd love he wouldn't  exist it's damn good it's like nothing  really matters to him right now  including me you gotta think real hard  about this do you have people that need  you no I'm taking the fight  Victor Drago son of Ivan Drago who  infamously killed Apollo Creed appeared  today to issue a challenge to Adonis  cream don't do this  I got a choice that's the same thing  your father said you died right here in  my hands  that kid was raised in Haiti dangerous  he broke things to me that I never been  fixed ain't worth it  it's not just us anymore a day I want to  rewrite history if you want to fight  this man that's your business  but don't pretend this is about your  father  this here is all about  it was right without  the tribulation  this won't be the end to me  are you  they can't because we're a team  [Music]  now you know what you fight before  Brown after brown you learn more about  yourself when I stepped in every it  wasn't all about me  [Music]